you know
you could see there was blood coming out
of her eyes and
blood coming out of her wherever
oh man i should run for president
she does have a very nice figure i've
said if she weren't my daughter perhaps
i'd be dating her
when mexico sends its people they're not
sending their best
they're not sending you they're sending
people with problems
and they're bringing their problems oh
that's a pretty picture
you dropping to your knees robert
pattinson should not take back kristen
stewart
she cheated on him like a dog like a dog
they're bringing drugs they're bringing
crime they're rapists
the concept of global warming was
created by and for the chinese
i have a great relationship with the
blacks i've always had a great
relationship with the blacks
hey girl
i would love to be a well-educated black
because i really do feel they have the
advantage
everyone knows that i'm right that
robert pattinson should dump kristen
stewart i mean in a couple of years
this will be all over and he will thank
me oh no
part of the beauty of me is that i'm
very rich i know the chinese i made a
lot of money with the chinese
i understand the chinese mind oh
i beat john all the time robert i'm
getting a lot of heat for saying that
you should dump kristen stewart but i'm
right
if you look if you saw the miss universe
girls you'd reconsider
black guy's counting my money i hate it
the only kind of people on one kind of
money are short guys that wear yamakas
every day
yeah laziness is a trait in blacks
i'm not racist you know when it comes to
racism and racist i'm the least racist
person there is
i am the least racist person well i'm
the least racist person you know
it doesn't really matter what you write
as long as you got a young and beautiful
piece of ass
hey what's the matter you got blood
coming out of your wherever
you know when it comes to racism and
racist i'm the least racist person there
is
ah hey i'm a whiner and i'm gonna keep
whining and whining until i win
okay